speaking of breakfast um so like since
as you guys as you guys know like i've
i've been on like a little bit of a diet
recently you know because uh gained a
lot of weight when i went back to
england
um i wouldn't exactly say recently
you've been on a diet for a while
because here's what happens right i go
on a diet for like a month have like a
week holiday either with the boys with
sydney pig out a bit gain on gain a bit
more weight so i'm still like i go back
to the diet after i'm back it's it's
like a healthy lifestyle i don't think
it's a diet i think you should eat any
help that's not a diet i mean i mean i
am eating healthy but i am definitely
taking in less calories than i it would
take to maintain weight so i'm not like
i'm not like this isn't a speed run but
it's like a it's it's like a slow
lose weight gain a little bit back it's
a slow run yeah it's a slow run it's a
slow run um and yeah the reason is uh
when i went back to england literally in
[ __ ] september or something uh i
gained a [ __ ] ton of weight because i
ate like [ __ ] and i drank every day and
i think like it was the first time that
i could physically feel my body had
gained weight so much that i remember
like i saw like a few comments of like
the before and after like trash taste
recordings after i came back trash
changed recording i think you can see
that i definitely i definitely did i
wouldn't say like overweight or anything
closer but you could definitely see i
did gain a little bit of weight so i've
been like working to
since since that one holiday working to
uh
working to lose that weight and now that
i'm taking in lower calories every day
i'm doing things that i wouldn't
normally do like uh having breakfast
because normally i just normally are you
a functioning member of society i know
right i know right i never eat breakfast
getting on his high horse i eat
breakfast yeah so because like you know
because i'm taking less calories i've
been getting hungry in the mornings and
so i'm like oh okay maybe maybe it's
time to start being a normal person uh
like everyone else in society and start
having breakfast like people like like
people like to talk about so have you
been enjoying it so
yeah so because that doesn't sound like
you're enjoying it i mean it's not so
much i'm enjoying it so much as i'm
eating because my body craves something
inside my stomach because
uh this is usually what hungary is yeah
that is that is what hunger is i don't
get hungry at all when i wake up no i
mean either i i never used to until i
started having like salads and
low-calorie meals every day and then i
started getting hungry in the morning
it's weird i only feel hungry in the
morning when i'm on a trip
yeah well when i'm at home i don't
actually know on a trip even on a trip
no really except if it's mcdonald's
breakfast
that that's the only breakfast i always
got time no no one of them might have a
vacation i'm like four meals a day
sounds about
eat yeah eat exactly
i wake up at like 7 a.m in a hotel room
like why am i so hungry yeah that's not
normal yeah so like me and sydney have
been starting to eat like cereal and i
remember like as i've like added cereal
to my diet if you've been following my
twitter you'd know what i'm about to say
but i remember like having i remember
like eating the cereal one day and i'm
just like
oh no i'm about to have a food take
and
and
brace
yourselves brace yourself i think i'm
about to have an opinion guys
um and i realized i think cereal is
better without milk oh god he said it
oh he said it and i'm
and i remember i remember i i remember
just eating one day and i just said it
casually to sydney uh and she looked at
me like i just murdered someone she just
dropped the spirit
she dropped the spoon in the milk
is that really that bad of a take
i mean apparently it is um
like you know weetabix in the uk as a
kid i usually just eat those dry
i think because i can understand that
because when you put that in milk it
just turns into wet cardboard yeah well
like i think it's better without milk i
i think that's i think that's what
anxious it's my mood you know some days
i want because you know it's a [ __ ]
challenge having to eat cereal without
milk it is it's like
yeah it's it's like you're eating you're
eating scooby snacks like well like your
dental workout is insane but like i i
hate it when you pour the milk in okay
and then the timer starts because
just pour less milk i just put less than
i need how much milk are you putting in
i mean i'm putting in the normal amount
of milk but it's clearly a lot you're
not yeah it's getting wet oh it's
getting soggy i hate soggy soup you
should put a little bit in and then mix
it like force it through the milk
but i also think that waters it down as
well you're having like cinnamon crunch
or something and then you i want the
cinnamon on the crunch i want the crunch
and the cinnamon together but like you
put the milk in i wouldn't put more milk
water it down wouldn't putting more milk
water no that's what that's what i'm
saying i don't want any milk in there
because i like the taste of cereal as it
is but if you just put a little bit of
milk just to wet it yeah just a wedding
yeah it like brings out the flavor i
literally put like the bare minimum milk
if i do and then i just keep like
rinsing it through the milk yeah that's
exactly what i do so that by the time
you finish it you only have like a tiny
pool of milk do you think it tastes
better with the milk in it though yeah i
just because most of the time when it's
a no milk i'm like tired by the end of
eating i'm like
i mean not that not that i really eat a
lot of cereal anymore but yeah every
time i do feel like a cereal like bottle
i just yeah it's my smell
you know i just
is is cereal that good for you i just
feel like cereal is like you don't need
it that much well it depends on the
cereal yeah it depends on the cereal
like a bowl of
grams of sugar what
what
what are they putting in this this
i think i think that's why i stopped
eating cereal uh not just because like i
started to not get hungry in the
mornings as i just got so bad for you
yeah
it depends on the cereal that you buy i
mean yeah i'm sure you know if you're
eating like a bowl of wheat picks right
then like yeah obviously that's got a
lot of you know health benefits but also
i don't want to start my morning with
wet cardboard in my mouth you know i
just don't want to start a morning like
that i'm sorry maybe you just hate wheat
makes jokes i do
i do i [ __ ] hate it i feel like maybe
there's just no saving like even like
with milk or without milk it just tastes
like [ __ ] to you i'm going to be
so non-australian when i say this i
[ __ ] hate weepics it's it's like and
you know people are like yeah just like
but you can just like add sugar or like
yogurt or like you know other things
into it i'm like well then that kind of
takes away from the health benefits give
me the yogurt just yeah just yeah i'll
just eat a top of yogurt that's fine see
like for me like cereal has always been
even even now as i see it i've always
felt that it feels like a snack right
because to me like to me people like
people have told me that they can't get
full
having cereal without milk and i'm just
like well to me it's like i'm not even
that hungry and breakfast you know to me
like cereal is just like a quick snack
before we get to lunch yeah that's your
chat in my in my lifetime i think i've
eaten more cereal past 1am than i
actually have in the morning like it is
it is the most perfect midnight snack i
really don't like eating cereal in the
evenings well what about like late at
night like as i mean last night no i
don't know because i've had it i always
it's actually really good
i mean i wish i liked it because then i
feel like that opens a lot of
possibilities yeah snacking options
unfortunately i don't know what you
snack at midnight then what's like your
mid your go-to midnight snack
i try and avoid it obviously at all
costs but crisps crisp stuff yeah but i
mean
it's just the most british thing you've
ever said
i love christians like i should have
seen this one coming up i was like i was
like like searching through the recesses
of my mind to think i know connor what
would he say and i'm like of course it
would be [ __ ] love chris you mean you
eat that as a meal though no sometimes
for a snack
i've seen your tweets
i've seen you eat doritos as a meal
don't lie to me listen there's no other
choice there's no other choice yeah
i don't know man there's always a choice
i don't feel good about it but i do it
i do it why ah they're good but like i
couldn't i i no matter how full i get
from eating just doritos yeah i can't in
my head i can't process that as this is
my meal yeah i do it and it doesn't feel
like a meal but i'm just so full that
it's like this will last till morning
i mean i'm sure i will
and then i'm in a lot of pain but it's
pretty good i've been there don't worry
i've been like yeah yeah i get i just
i'm not a big cereal guy i
i don't even like you did you eat it as
a kid because i can't remember because i
used to eat it a lot as a kid and i
don't remember the exact point that i
stopped eating cereal uh i swapped to
toast when i was a kid yeah after
halfway through school i must have
decided that i prefer toast so i'll eat
four pieces of toast i think i had a
very brief period from cereal to toast
and then it just very quickly went from
toast to nothing but i feel like toast
and cereal in like the same category of
not very good nutritional value but it's
not the worst thing in the world yeah
like it's not bad but it's also not
great actually you know the moment i
actually know the moment i switched from
toast to no breakfast was when i started
having coffees in the morning yeah no
tea for me too yeah like just having a
piece of toast with a hot drink you
can't beat it not even that for me it
was just like just replace the toast
with a cup of coffee wait what wait wait
what
like from like like i mean i do that now
yeah i do that now as well but like from
like i'd say for me maybe like 17 18. i
was just like yep coffee that's it